you know we all have a set of issues we
all have let's say a list of 10 things
that are important to us and we we rank
them right so for some people foreign
policy might be the first thing that's
important to them for something some
people taxes are number four uh for some
people states rights are here or
whatever it might be we all sort of
order that in our own brain whether
we're thinking about it or not and those
are the things that move us on voting
they might get a whole bunch of people
who had abortion pretty down low to now
put that at number one so it's a little
hard to say which way this this will
move people uh but
the issue is that we're all gonna be
talking about abortion and we got a
whole bunch of other problems uh there
might be an uh recession on the way
i think you put your finger on exactly
the dilemma you know i think a recession
is at this stage almost inevitable
because they don't control supply and
we've seen how volatile supply can be
with the shutdown in china
we also see uncertainty about oil prices
up and down et cetera and so you know as
i said earlier it's a witch's brew and
the probability of a recession is i
think unfortunately very very high
because their tool is crude and all they
can do is control aggregate demand
and by the way you know some people are
going to be harmed earlier than others
but you know they have no choice they've
got to maintain credibility which to to
date they've done reasonably well
that guy who we showed you right there
on cnbc that ain't nobody that's former
vice chair of the federal reserve roger
ferguson basically saying that a
recession is inevitable so now instead
of focusing on hey what can we do to
save the economy which the democrats and
biden have basically destroyed we're all
going to be screaming about abortion and
ironically we're not even going to be
screaming about the honest issues
related to abortion we're just going to
be screaming whether abortion is legal
or not which again has nothing to do
with roe v wade
you